when you have a look at this this is
just a quadratic equation isn't it so in
fact we've been solving this
for a number of years in many regards
there's not too much here that
you don't already know in terms of how
to solve this
how would you normally look an equation
like this and try and solve any
suggestions yeah go ahead jeff uh
in this case if that five two and one
weird numbers you just
formulated yeah sure if you're looking
at these and you're like
i do not know the number that when i um
a pair of numbers rather that adds to
negative 2
and multiplies to 5 i'm
struggling a little bit to work out a
nice easy factorization that shouldn't
surprise you because
we're looking at these guys right you
know when you're guessing at numbers by
insects inspection you think
oh it might be 2 and 3 or negative 4 and
8. all that kind of thing
we can think of integers pretty easily
but there are so many more combinations
of complex numbers because you've got
the real
axis and you've got the imaginary axis
as well um in most cases you're going to
say forget it
i'm just going to go to the formula okay
so i'm going to start you off and then
i'm going to let you
loose the quadratic formula we know this
pretty well right what are we going to
start with
minus b which in this case is
negative two right plus or minus square
root of okay what's coming underneath
here
yeah so it's going to be um four because
i get that from negative two
all squared and then i'm going to go
minus
four ac yeah five times one so you can
see i'm going to get 20 from that
shortly okay
i'm going to divide that all by two
yeah 2 times 5 which in this case will
give me 10. now
even before you started to do much
working out you can already see
why this fits under this category and
our discriminant is negative
in real number land we would get to this
point and say oh i don't need to worry
about this anymore
no real solutions but we're in the
complex plane so i want you to go and
proceed think about all the things you
know about how we define imaginary
numbers
get an answer out i might give you um a
minute and a half to have a go at that
off you go
how did you go did you did you arrive
like i did
maybe you arrived so long ago you're
like i've already started having a look
at the next couple that's okay before we
do that
let's just make sure we know what's
going on here okay
we have a real equation sorry an
equation with real coefficients but
we've landed
on a complex solution because we have a
negative discriminant and that's fine we
know how to deal with negative
uh sorry the square root of negative 16.
now we hardly bat an eyelid okay
so we've got both of our square roots in
there plus minus
4i and then just a little bit of
simplifying okay so is that all right
happy with that so you're gonna
encounter plenty of these and
questions like this are going to arrive
when we try and solve
not just square roots but the nth roots
of complex numbers which as you see
we'll get on to later on but it becomes
a bit more meaty when you start looking
at
monsters like this right even just look
at the equation you're like uh
okay now what i'm going to suggest we do
is um you can go about this question
more or less exactly the same way that
you did this one okay however
i'm going to encourage you to uh try a
different path um for a couple of
reasons
the quadratic formula right essentially
what it is is an automation
of an older technique that you learned
earlier an algebraic technique which is
kind of
neat and fancy but then like as soon as
you've got a formula for it you're like
why do i need this technique this
algorithm just can use the formula
does anyone remember what's the formula
sorry what's the the process
the thinking underneath the quadratic
formula that gave it to us yeah it is
completing the square
like this plus or minus the square root
of etc it came from us
rearranging ax squared plus bx plus c
once you rearrange it you have to divide
by some stuff and then you end up with
this
if you make x the subject now what i'm
going to encourage you to do
and you'll see why as we progress
through the question when you have
complex coefficients completing this
square turns out to be
probably a nicer neater way to set it
out than the quadratic formula you'll
arrive at the same solution okay
but let's have a go at this okay i'm
going to begin by saying in order to
write this in a way that's useful for
completing the square i actually want
this term and this term my two
terms with z of them i want them sort of
by themselves okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write z squared i'm also going to
factorize
2 out of that and you'll see why in a
second if you're remembering how
complete the square works
and then there's my z i'm going to leave
them on the left hand side
and then i'm going to take this constant
i'm going to do whatever i need to do to
get the constant terms on the right hand
side so in this case what should i add
to both sides
5 minus 2i thank you so that's over
there so nothing has changed to this at
the moment
but you can see what i've done is i've
kind of thought to myself i'm going to
complete the square in a second
so i've left this spot here for the
completing the square
bit right um to complete the square we
have to add
a certain thing and maybe you're seeing
now why i've took out factor two
what's the thing i have to add one plus
three
one plus three i or squared perfect so
where this comes from if you recall
is you take this coefficient here you
have it then you square it
half and then square um this two i
factorize out so that this is just the
half
and then here's the square of course you
can't just add it to the left hand side
you've got to add it
to the right hand side as well so far so
good is that okay so i've actually
completed the square now but the whole
point in doing that is so that i could
factorize
the left hand side and this is now
currently in the form
my right underneath actually in this
color this is in the form a
squared minus two a b plus
b squared do you see that so i can write
it as a minus b
or squared which is exactly what i'm
going to do now so my a is just
z what's my b
have a look at how i factorized it it's
just going to be
1 plus 3i do you agree with that 1 plus
3i and that is all squared there's my
factorization
and then over here on the right i might
as well start to simplify this thing so
i'm going to go 5
minus 2i when we have a go at this guy
you're going to get a squared plus
2 a b plus
b squared what's 3i all squared
yeah it's nine i squared which is minus
nine so i'll write that minus nine along
the end there okay
when you have a look at this left-hand
side looks good it's factorized but in
order to uh
tidy this up i'm going to get something
on the right hand side here by
collecting
some like terms so i think that i can
see
real real real so when you put them all
together what's going to be your real
term now you have three imaginary term
plus 4i okay now on the left hand side
we still have this thing that's being
squared
so clearly to make z the subject i'm
going to need to
take the square roots of both sides now
at this point here
you can see why we had to wait until we
developed our understanding of square
roots
of complex numbers to be able to tackle
things like this right because you will
end up with something complex here
and then you've got to take the square
root of it now you would go and do this
as a separate process
but luckily for you it's almost like it
was designed on purpose
you already know what the square roots
of this particular number are
they're plus or minus 1 plus 2i do you
agree plus or minus the
all of one plus 2y so if i take the
square roots of both sides you're gonna
get this guy
and the left-hand side is no longer
squared okay with that are you tracking
now this point here um i don't need this
working in the right-hand side anymore
so i'm going to
get rid of it at this point here you're
very close to getting
z aren't you um you just need to add
1 plus 3i to both sides and then there's
going to be more collecting of like
terms
with this guy here right so let's go
ahead and do that line
i'll add 1 plus 3i to both sides
here's my plus minus of this
so at this point we've got a negative
case
this minus this and a positive case this
plus this right
can you go ahead and tell me what the uh
negative case will be
what happens to the real parts when
you're subtracting 1
minus 1. it cancels that's nice and then
you've got 3i minus
2i so you just get one of your solutions
being i
that's convenient um and then you've got
another solution that comes from adding
them so
1 plus 1 gives you 2. what will the
imaginary component be
plus 5i and those are
our two complex solutions from our
equation
with complex coefficients does that make
sense so you do need to take a bit of
care
obviously in your working for subsequent
questions
this line here will require a bit of
extra work because you're gonna be like
uh what uh
what are the square roots of this thing
i need to work that out separately but
then you'll progress through
as you just saw okay question two right
and i admit this is partly my fault for
the way i've leaned you right i talked
to you this was about solving equations
and then you have this set of skills
that's very useful and you can just use
over and over again
except for this teeny teeny problem that
you could get presented with objects
like these
which are not equations uh there's no
they're not equal to anything
no equal sign not an equation these are
expressions right
so how do we factorize these well rather
than saying
this equals 0 which we don't actually
know
you could say i want to consider if it
were equal to zero and then go ahead and
use a formula
but there's a much easier way and i can
do it for both of them just using the
algebraic tools
you already know for instance i know
this doesn't look like a nice neat thing
to factorize
at the moment but let me change it into
something that
is nice and easy to factorize
you're looking at thinking this is this
is still not better for me
i'm not i'm not seeing it right i'm not
feeling the love that's okay
tell me the moment at which it clicks
for you
wha what am i doing here i've got
squares i've got squares
that doesn't look like a square but it
is
it is to us this is i squared 6 squared
isn't it
right so therefore you're like oh this
is 6i all squared
so therefore i can just write this sorry
that's a squared
i can just write this with an a minus b
a plus b factorization
and it's done okay now when you have a
look at this
uh it's not exactly the same there's not
going to be such a nice neat difference
of squares in here but
remember how we were looking before you
don't just have the quadratic formula
at your disposal you don't just have
difference of squares you can say
i can find the part of this that i can
turn into a square
right this thing i can complete by
adding what
think look at this i have and then i
square
right so that would be in this case one
but you don't actually have one in this
equation that's all right you have more
than one
so you just separate the one out from
the rest of it right does that make
sense
so you're like now what i've got here is
a square
and this doesn't look like difference of
squares but i've already illustrated
that it's not hard
to change it into that form does that
make sense so i guess what i'm trying to
say is
number one be cautious of turning
expressions
into equations and number two now that
you have complex numbers up your belt up
your sleeve
you can actually not just handle
difference of squares you can handle
sums
of squares okay